Ah, Hollywood.
It's a town where the streets are paved with
gold…and dreams die every single day.
Seriously, where's that Goonies sequel we
were promised?
And what the heck happened to Inception 2?
But while plenty of sequels to mega-hit films
have struggled and failed to claw their way
out of development hell, few follow-ups have
endured more setbacks than Gladiator 2.
The long-awaited follow-up to one of Ridley
Scott's most popular movies, Gladiator 2 has
valiantly tried to battle its way into theaters.
But every time it rises up, the film is beaten
back down.
It's time to grab your sword and helmet and
finally figure out what happened.
Well, Maximus is dead
When Gladiator hit theaters in 2000, the sword-and-sandal
epic wowed critics — it currently holds
an impressive score on Rotten Tomatoes — and
it took home $457 million at the worldwide
box office.
The movie also fared well during awards season,
taking home the Oscar for Best Picture and
nabbing the Best Actor prize for Russell Crowe.
The film pretty much turned Crowe into an
international superstar, and nearly two decades
later, people still shout lines like this:
"Are you not entertained?"
Naturally, with such a massive hit on their
hands, DreamWorks was quick to start developing
a sequel.
There was just one major, Coliseum-sized problem
with the idea: Maximus Decimus Meridius, the
main character of the movie, is kinda, y'know,
dead.
In the film's climactic moments, the evil
Emperor Commodus, played by Joaquin Phoenix,
challenges Maximus to a gladiator battle.
There's no universe where Joaquin Phoenix
beats Russell Crowe in hand-to-hand combat,
so Commodus evens the odds by secretly stabbing
Maximus before tossing him into the arena.
Luckily, Maximus is fueled by revenge and
righteous anger.
Fighting through the pain, Maximus kills Commodus
with the emperor's own weapon before drifting
away into the wheat-filled afterlife.
It was a killer ending for a standalone film.
But it certainly makes things tricky for a
sequel.
But hey, Hollywood had gotten around this
kind of problem before, right?
Prequel problems
These days, prequels are all the rage, with
everything from Star Wars, to X-Men, and the
Alien franchise going back to move forward.
DreamWorks was looking to do the same thing
to get Maximus back into the world of the
living.
When people started whispering about a new
Gladiator movie in 2001, the word on the web
was that the story would take place years
before the events of the first film.
It was said to focus on Maximus' early days
in the Roman military, showing the Spaniard's
rise from mere soldier to mighty general.
Producer Douglas Wick declared talks were
underway to get the ball rolling, saying:
”You don't finally do something like [Gladiator
2] unless you have a dazzling story to tell."
The studio was reportedly looking to pay Crowe
as much as $20 million to head back into the
arena.
The studio lined up David Franzoni, one of
the original movie's writers, to put the script
together.
But, much like a Roman mob, Hollywood can
be fickle —
“Maximus the Merciful!”
- and the project never made it out of development.
Shifting to a sequel
Sometime between 2001 and 2002, DreamWorks
decided to put the brakes on a Gladiator prequel
and shift their focus to a sequel.
The first big change involved David Franzoni
stepping away from his typewriter to produce.
The writing gig then went to John Logan, another
one of the original Gladiator writers.
With a new guy putting words on the page,
the story was suddenly set 15 years after
the events of the original film.
That same year, producer Walter Parkes hinted
the film might possibly jump back and forth
in time, but it would mainly tell the story
of Lucius, the royal son of Lucilla.
It would’ve followed Lucius as the last
heir of Marcus Aurelius as he sought out his
true father — who, we would have discovered,
would turn out to be Maximus.
Director Ridley Scott seemed on board with
the idea, even declaring that Logan's script
was ready to go at one point.
However, the sequel was going to be significantly
different from the first film when it came
to action.
As Scott explained, he wasn't going to "touch
gladiators again" — a potentially controversial
choice for a movie tentatively called "Gladiator
2."
Instead, Scott was more interested in the
political arena and wanted to focus on "politics
and praetorians" rather than blood and guts.
Scott also expected to start filming in 2005,
but as 2004 faded into memory, Gladiator 2
was still stuck in the cinematic mud.
But, work continued, and the film eventually
morphed into one of the greatest movies never
made.
Nick Cave's Christ Killer
If you've ever heard a Nick Cave song, then
you know the Australian artist is basically
an old-timey prophet armed with a guitar.
His songs are brutal, apocalyptic, and spiritual
in an Old Testament sort of way, and you get
that same vibe watching the movies he's been
involved with over the years.
Cave has composed music for films like Hell
or High Water and The Assassination of Jesse
James by the Coward Robert Ford.
He's also written scripts for movies like
Lawless and The Proposition.
With that kind of cinematic mind, it's not
surprising that Russell Crowe saw potential
in Cave's fire-and-brimstone brain, asking
Cave to write the screenplay for Gladiator
2.
What is a bit surprising is how absolutely
insane the script turned out to be.
Cave didn't disappoint when it came to figuring
out how to follow-up Maximus’ death.
The project was titled "Christ Killer," and
would’ve opened in the afterlife, with Maximus
realizing he's dead.
Unfortunately, there's nary a wheat field
in sight, and his wife and child are nowhere
to be seen.
Eventually, the gladiator comes face-to-face
with the dying gods.
The decrepit deities make a deal with Maximus,
promising to guide him to his family if he'll
kill a god who's gone rogue — one who's
betrayed the Roman faith and now professes
belief in the "one, true God."
As Maximus agrees to do their dirty work,
he eventually winds up on Earth, several years
in the future.
After returning to the real world, he discovers
little Lucius has grown up to be a savage
soldier, one with a bad habit of violently
murdering Christians.
Maximus eventually takes a stand with the
persecuted Christians, leading an army against
the Roman legions, but after his victory,
he's cursed to go through time as an immortal,
fighting in countless wars and popping up
in every conflict from the Crusades to Vietnam.
If you think that sounds wild, we didn't even
mention the purgatory scene, the Coliseum
filled with alligators, or the finale that
takes place inside the Pentagon.
Yeah, the one in Washington, D.C.
Cave described the script as "a stone-cold
masterpiece."
Sure.
Why not?
Not over yet
It’s been pretty quiet the past decade,
but Ridley Scott still hasn’t given up on
Gladiator.
In March of 2017, Scott said he does "know
how to bring him back," in reference to Maximus.
So, never give up, right?
Maximus wouldn't.
“UNGH!”
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!